Here's everything my toddlers ate today.
I just wanna start off by saying that
they eat whatever my husband and I eat.
We don't make them any separate meals.
This is also not what everyday looks like.
So I started off with breakfast.
They had a cup of milk
and then I started making this French toast casserole.
Combined all of my wet ingredients
and then poured them over my sliced up sourdough bread.
And then I made a crumble topping to go on top
before I popped in the oven.
In the meantime,
I also made a peach vanilla puree to go on top.
Once it was cold,
I served them up a piece with that puree
and some cherries,
and that was their breakfast.
Lunchtime rolled around.
I always need a lunchtime pick me up.
You guys know that
today was iced mango juice.
I've just been craving mangoes.
Then I got started on making some pasta
and letting that rest
while I thinly sliced up my fennel and onions.
Cause I was making a caramelized fennel and onion pasta.
I let that go on the stove
while I rolled out my pasta dough.
This was such a simple dish to make,
but it tasted so good.
And once that was done,
I just toss the pasta in the sauce.
I also added some peas
and then topped all of that
with a lot of Parmesan cheese.
Tied them over until dinner.
I made them a little snack.
These oranges are so good.
They also had some pickles that they wanted more of
and the granola bars I made the other day.
Then I wanted an early dinner,
so I made roasted potatoes.
I started by peeling about four russet potatoes
and chopping them up into large cubes
and then par boiling them.
So a little secret.
Add baking soda to your water.
Once those were done,
I strained them
and then shook them in the pot
before pouring them in my hot skillet
that was coated in duck fat.
I let those go in the oven for about an hour,
but I kept flipping them
to get an even crust on all sides.
Cut up some Brussels sprouts
and then seasoned my chicken with some salt and pepper
before hand searing it.
I basted it with some butter,
thyme, and Rosemary
and put that in the oven to finish off.
And I made some quick balsamic
and honey glazed Brussels sprouts
before letting my chicken rest.
Then I plated it all up
and I had some leftover gravy in the fridge
that I thought
was gonna go perfect with this. And it did.